[Musique]
osez recevoir des
critiques quand vous osez apparaître sur
la place publique il y a les critiques
dites professionnelles la critique qui
est d à votre
métier avez-vous déjà ressenti une pluie
in on plus de commentaires une vague de
chaleur vous arriz des commentaires
après une simple publication qui
s'enchaîne qui s'enchaîne votre natel
des appels des amis des WhatsApp des
artisans mon dieu il y a un commentaire
négatif et
là tout s'enflamme ou tout simplement
une soirée entre amis en famille où vous
parlez de votre propre projet vous avez
travaillé dur dessus est dur et là en
une simple phrase une flèche vient vous
tirer exactement sur un point sensible
que vous n'avez forcément pas forcément
réfléchi et là en quelques
secondes vous s
frondre quand vous osez apparaître sur
la place publique il y a aussi la
critique dite personnelle et là
malheureusement vous ne pourrez pas
arrêter ces critiques personnelles sur
une
caractéristique qui vous rend différent
des autres je m'explique je suis
tranquillement devant l'épicerie en
train de faire une petite vidéo pour
montrer un nouveau produit c'est lundi
matin il fait beau tout content j'ai
fait mon ma vidéo en autoportrait je la
publie et là un petit commentaire en
message privé salut Clément longtemp
parevu franchement je te dis ça pour ton
bien mais franchement fais attention à
ta santé de prendre du poids comme tu
l'as fait c'est vraiment pas bien fais
comme moi fais du sport c'est simple non
comme si la réponse à cette question
était si simple et oui toutes ces
critiques qui fusent qui t'envahissent
qui te transpersent au plus profond de
toi Clément ton t-shirt on voit ton
ventre et d toi le bébé devant 10
personnes bien sûr serait trop simple et
d donc toi le bébé c'est tu es à combien
tuas 3 4 mois ou bien dis moi c'est
pratique toi la piscine tu as pas besoin
de bouer dis donc tu es sûr que tu
travailles mais la tête que tu te payes
sur cette vidéo tu nous saoules avec ton
coucou c'est Clément toi tu dois pas
manger avec des graines dis donc c'est
tellement dommage avant tu étais
tellement jolie mais la cabine que tu te
payes comme si la réponse à ces
questions éit
simple
j'ai une maladie qui s'appelle la
boulémie moi c'est Clément je suis
épicier et c'est le plus beau métier du
monde j'ai ouvert mon épicerie il y a 6
ans et là avant d'ouvrir j'avais fait un
financement participatif dans ce
financement participatif j'avais mis les
plus beaux concepts écrits j'avais
vraiment tout analyser et gen de choses
mais j'avais peur d'une
chose c'est d'apparaître sur la place
publique
de montrer ma tête de mettre mon nom
associé à ce projet avant d'ouvrir
plusieurs personnes me disaient mais tu
es dans un village ça va pas forcément
fonctionner tu es sûr de vouloir faire
ça mais je voulais absolument faire ce
que j'aime prendre un produit et lui
mettre trois axes le produit avec une
certaine distance le moins possible
entre le fournisseur et
l'épicerie le produit qui soit sain et
surtout qu'il soit
bon j'ai ouvert l'épicerie et du coup ma
fois obligé de me lancer sur la place
publique et là ça fonctionnait j'avais
du monde j'avais des commentaires qui
arrivaient je savais plus comment gérer
j'ai dû engager tout de suite et là la
même chose des petits commentaires qui
arrivaient mais c'est bizarre lui ça
fonctionne mais il doit avoir quelque
chose de douteux derrière quand
même faisons gaffe et à chaque critique
qui me venait je le prenais à cœur comme
si j'étais sur un ring de box et je
devais répondre absolument tout de suite
comme si la personne qui venait ça
faisait comme une poudrière et 100
personnes tout d'un coup penser la même
chose je voulais absolument répondre je
vous absolument avoir la perfection dans
ma réponse je voulais être parfait grave
erreur comment di
pouvons-nous transformer ces critiques
en catalyseur de croissance comment
pouvons-nous les transformer pour en
faire une chance et les tourner en notre
faveur il y a deux formes de critique la
forme dite orale la forme face- à
faceace là on est entre deux
personnes je me demande
toujours la personne qui est en face
elle a pas forcément les mêmes attentes
la même perception de ce qu'elle
veut du coup j'essaie absolument de
mettre à sa pass je me dis quel besoin
cette personne a me dire ça je reçois la
critique et je vous avoue au début
j'avais pas absolument toutes les
réponses du coup j'avais une petite
technique qui était ma la pokerkerf je
répondais quelle bonne suggestion je
note et je reviens vers vous mais merci
de m'avoir donné cette
suggestion et et là en fait je prenais
la critique et je la laissa se massérer
je disais est-ce qu'il y a un fond de
vérité là derrière est-ce que je peux
trouver une bonne
idée est-ce que il y a des choses que je
peux pas faire j'essayais de structurer
mon raisonnement et trè exercice que je
me faisais et là c'est vrai que c'est
assez facile de mettre dans le placard
et dire ça ira mieux demain je me posais
la question attends quand tu as reçu
cette critique qu'est-ce qui bonnait en
toi quelle émotion tu as reçu pourquoi
tu as eu cet agacement pourquoi ça monté
en toi tu avais juste envie de répondre
mais bon qu'est-ce que ça peut te hein
ouais bon voilà et j'essayais vraiment
d'analyser mais pourquoi je commençais
un peu à Trans transpiré pourquoi ça m'a
agacé cette
critique il y a la critique aussi dit
écrite sur les réseaux sociaux où là la
personne elle est derrière vot son écran
elle vous vous fait une critique sur un
commentaire Facebook sur un un sur votre
page Google cette critique peut être
beaucoup plus asserbe et pointu mais
peut-être le petit avantage qu'on peut
en tirer c'est qu'il y a pas forcément
de gestion des émotions quand vous la
recevez vous êtes dans votre ordinateur
vous pouvez pleurer vous pouvez crier
sur l'ordinateur c'est l'ordinateur donc
il y a au moins vous gérez pas votre
émotion mais il y a peut-être dans cette
critique pas une personne deux qui l'ont
mais il y a peut-être 100 voire 200
voire 1000 personnes qui peuvent la lire
et là j'essaie absolument d'en faire
exactement le même exercice me dire oh
qu'est-ce que je peux tirer de ça est-ce
qu'il y a un fond de vérité comment je
peux y répondre donner de la valeur à la
réponse pour moi ce qui compte quand je
donne une critique quand je donne une
critique quand je donne une réponse à la
critique je souhaite vraiment être bien
dans mes baskets je me dis quand je la
donne est-ce que je suis bien avec ça si
je suis bien malgré les contraintes
malgré que je peux pas tout faire et que
j'ai expliqué mes
contraintes ça devrait convenir mais
attention ça veut pas dire que quand on
donne une réponse à une critique qu'il
faut pas évoluer parce que il y a un
client peut-être de semaines après vient
vous dire une solution une phrase en une
phrase VI vous déconstruire ce que vous
avez réfléchi pendant 20 minutes vous
dites
mais mais lui en une phrase en fait il
m'a trouvé une meilleure solution
qu'est-ce que je fais j'enlève mes
basquettes blanches je mets les Noirs
voilà je me dis bah ouais j'évolue je
reste pas strictement dans une idée je
grandis ce qui compte ce n'est pas le
résultat mais le chemin que nous prenons
pour
l'atteindre je vous av je vous avoue
cher public que je me suis fait
avoir je me suis fait avoir par les 5 %
de critique
négativ
pourquoi je me suis dit peut-être c'est
plus simple de me dire bah voilà
qu'est-ce que je vais mettre une vidéo
et tro quatre commentaires sur mon
physique ah je suis fatigué ai-je besoin
de
ça ai-je besoin de ça et j'ai changé il
y a une année à cause de ces critiques
et c'est en par cette présentation je me
suis rendu
compte la communication de mon
entreprise je souhaite être purement
authentique et je vous promets que j'ai
répondu à tous mes commentaires Google
peu importe et j'ai vraiment essayer
aussi les commentaires Facebook d'y
répondre je me disais mais en fait avant
j'avais peut-être aussi une logique
qu'un commentaire négatif quand on y
répond on lui donne peut-être de la
valeur ou de la visibilité mais je me
disais aussi en fait si je réponds à ce
commentaire la personne qui lit ce
commentaire va lire aussi ma réponse du
coup j'essaie de faire un objet
marketing et d'y mettre de
l'humour voici un commentaire que j'ai
reçu sur ma page
Google il faut avoir le porte-monnaie
bien rempli personn agréable une étoile
voilà vous recevez ça vous êtes pas bien
je vous promets ma
réponse merci infiniment d'avoir partagé
vos pensées avec nous porte-monnaie bien
rempli et bien nous aimons penser que
nos étagères sont un peu comme la salle
de trésors d'un dragon rempli de
merveilles à découvrir notre personnel
agréable travaille dur pour faire de
chaque visite une expérience mémorable
nous sommes tellement chanceux d'avoir
des clients comme vous qui ajoutent une
touche de magie à notre épicerie votre
présence illumine notsre journées comme
le soleil du matin sur un champ de
fraise avec votre gratitude gourmande
bisous voilà vous avez dans ce
commentaire tout ce qui me représente
c'est un peu trop long bah oui bah oui
Clément il y a le bisou à la fin et
j'essaie vraiment de faire en fait que
ça me ressemble et c'est grâce à vous
j'ai pu répondre à ce commentairire
essayons déjà de faire de notre mieux
c'est ça l'excellence c'est de faire de
son mieux la perfection n'a jamais fait
partie de notre monde mais l'excellence
oui mesdames et messieurs
osez essayer de faire de votre mieux
merci
beaucoup